[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Hello.
I'm Jen Person for
The Developer Show.
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Staged releases on
Android allow you
to manage the inherent
risks of a new release
by making a new
version of your app
available to just a
fraction of your users.
And staged releases are now
possible on testing tracks, as
well as the production track.
To take a closer look at
how staged releases work
and how you can use them as
part of your release process,
head on over to the post linked
in the description below.
We recently
announced that we are
evolving the design
of Wear OS by Google,
and providing quicker
access to your information
and notifications.
Take a look at the post to
learn about the new notification
stream and how you can make
the most out of notifications
on the redesigned
Wear OS by Google.
Google Cloud and Unity
recently announced
the availability of an open
source matchmaking project
called Open Match to help you
focus on just the matchmaking
logic--
that's the inputs in logic
for selecting players--
instead of building
a whole matchmaker
from scratch for each game.
More details and a link to the
GitHub repo are on the post.
Firebase provides real-time
streams and async callbacks
to do all sorts of awesome
things in your app.
Getting data from one
stream is easy enough,
but what if you want to
join it from another?
Combining multiple async
streams of data can get complex,
so we created a new
JavaScript library called
RxFire to simplify things.
Take a look at the
post for a video
and plenty of example code.
We're committed to transparency
and a thriving developer
community, which is why we
started open sourcing our SDKs
last year.
Recently, we continued on
that mission by open sourcing
our first Firebase
Android SDKs, including
our Cloud Firestore,
Cloud Functions,
and real-time database SDKs.
The GitHub link is on the post.
To help you ship secure
cryptographic code,
we developed Tink, a
multi-language cross-platform
cryptographic library.
At Google, Tink is
already being used
to secure the data of
products, such as AdMob,
Google Pay, Google
Assistant, Firebase,
and the Android search app.
It just recently
hit version 1.2.0,
which now supports Cloud,
Android, iOS and more.
Take a look at the post for some
example code and all the links.
It's been 10 years since
Chrome was first released.
A lot has changed
since then, but we've
kept our goal of building a
solid foundation for modern web
applications.
In Chrome 69,
we've added support
for CSS Scroll Snap, Display
Cutouts, the Web Locks
API, and more.
For the detail and a video,
head on over to the post
linked in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Maybe they didn't hear me.
Ah!